what is up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 10 of 3d game
programming in Java now I know that it's
been a while since the last tutorial and
I'm really sorry for having to release
this late but unfortunately I'm no
longer able to release one episode every
day because you know I've got I've got
work I've got school I've got a ton of
other stuff and I just I don't have time
basically
so you'll you guys will be getting one
sort of long episode ten plus minutes
episode every week okay once a week and
that'll probably be Sunday at this point
um Sunday Sunday probably Sunday I'm
evening in Australia I don't they'll
probably be like like Sunday morning in
the US or something I don't know what
country but in Australian Eastern
Standard Time probably around 8 p.m. on
Sunday 8 to 9 p.m. on Sunday so that's
that's the deal with the episodes one
Episode per week now also ah thanks for
everyone for for subscribing because I
hit 100 subscribers so thanks a lot for
that I know 100 isn't too much but you
know that's pretty good I'm already like
a quarter of the way to 200 so that's
awesome
um and a quick shout out to AJ spottin
because his name will be on the screen
for being the 100th subscriber go ahead
and check out his channel and tell them
the Turner says hi and thanks for
subscribing um ok so we're going to move
on um and um I asked you guys last time
if you guys would prefer for me to start
on on tech on textures or explaining and
all of you guys seem to think that
explaining was the way to go so that's
what I'm ha ha ha I'm kidding I'm
kidding ok like 90% of you guys when I
made it a texture so that's what I want
to do um for those of you who wanted me
to explain all I will explain probably
later though so we are going to start on
textures we're probably not going to get
to textures this episode because I
really want to talk about sort of you
know builders 3d stuff don't talk about
it but add to it and sort of make it
actually look nice so yeah that's what
we're going to get onto right now ok so
last time we are we sort of had this
this little this thing and what we want
to do now is sort of I guess you can see
these sort of
squares and we need them to be squares
so I guess think of this sort of as
Minecraft in a way it's not obvious land
it'll look nothing like Minecraft when
it's done but um we're going to be where
basically what what we're going to do is
we're going to use square sort of
textures so we need a sort of draw
squares here and obviously you know this
is just this is like this got holes you
can see the black stuff it's not solid
we want to basically draw up squares top
and bottom and the way we're going to do
that is okay this stuff is really
confusing me actually these are naming
okay okay quick tip if you want to
rename like a variable or something or a
method or something in Java don't just
go ahead and rename it because well in
this case it's fine because you can you
know you have to update the name so if
we rename this to like to like I don't
know why wait I don't know why D we'll
have to copy and paste as you know here
but if if we sort of have this variable
and when we're using it in like tons of
different classes and stuff you can you
can tell that you know that's gonna
that's going to take a while so instead
of doing that we can just right click
hit refactor and hit rename or old shift
R is the shortcut and simply you know I
simply give it a name
y day and watch this as well look at
everything it updates everywhere and it
hit enter when you're done and you're
good I think I'll just name it I wonder
why why it's going to sort of name it um
Y wall actually help look at me I'm not
even doing doing one of those so it's
alt shift are thank you okay Y wall it's
not really stealing I'll name it ceiling
this is sort of like the ceiling at the
moment and what's not really the ceiling
it's just it's like the y-value should
probably call it a Y or something but
was already taken um before I think of a
good name was called ceiling for now and
depth I guess we'll just yeah let's call
that Duffner um okay so the first thing
we're probably going to do is I just see
here okay
this little live code this
so for this I'm going to let's just pop
that back to 2.0 so what we get
yeah it's nice just ah divide that by
height okay and I just come in here as
out okay let's just lower this bit make
some room for result for ourselves
yeah okay that's nice um okay what about
yeah okay so let's just let's set this
to tour at the moment and you'll
understand this in a minute um what else
do I want to do I want to come in here
oh yeah I want to do sort of the same
thing here as well so want to divide
this whole thing by height oh wow that
failed okay
that's right oh yeah we need to make
another integer YY and put a cost that
as well and that will be our LZ value
okay let's see
okay that's fine and we'll add YY to
this so we get okay interesting
okay so a lot of this is just basically
trial on our um okay now that does a
little route right yeah that should work
okay let's try and um multiply these by
16 x 16 so this gives us let's just add
8 okay that's so nice
actually we should probably shift this
okay
interesting
okay so at this point this is looking
quite interesting what else oh we need
to do
think about looking about right actually
um let's just bump that up yeah it
should be fun I can't really tell at
this point because we haven't finished
this okay let me just quickly system dot
out dot print line or just print X X so
we get where as icons all gone
what okay it should open our console
automatically I don't know why it's not
doing that oh wow that's not good it's
printing zeros xx hmm it seems to be
wrong with our xx
what about YY I think Y's printing
something should be yeah y is working I
guess we got a bit of a problem with our
x value yeah again guys if you if you
sort of system dot out dot print line
printing printing variables is a he's
just so good because it helps you
diagnose the problem really well so
that's like a sort of like a tip run
real quick right there it's really
important to do that actually I think I
know why I think yeah we forgot the
point zero here there we go there we go
right there okay you see that you see
that Diagnostics right there guys I'll
explain that in a bit
wonderful okay yeah awesome we have got
with what squares that was easy
um awesome okay let me just die I just
wanna this is really important I just
want to touch a bit on Diagnostics right
there what I did there was I am i okay I
was getting a problem where basically um
you know I was I wasn't getting you know
I'm like hang on this is weird it's it's
not working obviously this isn't this
isn't cubes
this isn't like this isn't it this isn't
it is an our our intended result our
desired result what's not working in
here so I went ahead and I'm like okay
let's let's check out the the X you know
so let's print basically the X values
all look they're all 0 something's
obviously not working if we run at the Y
values look at that they're working
obviously they're giving numbers so
there's nothing wrong with our Y there's
something wrong with our X because it's
giving our zeros so I immediately
thought okay well let's let's go back to
our integer xx it's getting this
information from dead flesh let's check
out death okay this is def OH
on it doesn't have the point zero at the
end let's put that in blue that is a
change and all that so if you guys don't
know what's wrong with your program with
your whatever system dot out dot print
line a variable which you suspect might
not be working and you'll basically see
so that's that's something that it's
really important um okay so we've we've
that's really good actually that's a
really good start
um I think will I
mmm I want to check out the animation
for this real quick I want to sort of
animate this and it's going to be pretty
easy to do that I'll just make it an
integer called time so that is 0 I just
called a time you can call off sick or
whatever you want and then I'm just
going to go ahead and say time plus plus
so basically what that's going to do is
it's going to increase the variable of
time by by whatever but every time it
can places for loop because it's inside
the for loop and if we go ahead and
check this out
if we sort of add let's add 50 to this
yeah ok so it's sort of it moves it
across yeah because I'll just see how
that moves it across the screen ok I
will see um so let's add time to here
Wow
ok so yeah so as you can see you know
time time changes every time it sort of
renders which means that it's going to
sort of be Z plus 1 first answer plus
2000 plus 3 and increases every time and
because it changes that results in
animation and I think I don't know if
this is a bit better on the screen must
be the screen recorder so spazzing out
here but it looks like it's going too
fast let's set this equal to 0.5 and we
need to probably change this double
actually
some debug it was also even faster 0:05
Wow we must be going down fast there we
go awesome okay so that seems to be
working that's actually fine okay don't
worry about all this will will cut off
the render distance here and away any
100 that's fantastic actually this
framerate is brilliant right now because
further wrong actually let's just I want
to quickly test this at a higher
resolution just to UM just to test out
the framerate of stuff okay so we're
getting okay that's that's fine we're
getting about 50 frames per second
don't worry rattle this will sort of
will cut the render distance down so it
doesn't actually render past say here
and that will actually increase the FPS
of course because it doesn't need to
render render stuff so we'll we'll do
that fog thing basically if you think of
you know of games how they have a
limiter as to help you know so how much
distance I guess it renders we're going
to add some fog there and make it all
nice and that should that that will give
us higher FPS so yeah I want a pretty
fast computer though which is why I
can't really tell if if that's low not
um another thing if you guys are making
games and stuff and you got like a
really powerful computer occasionally
you know X export it basically export it
and bring it onto like a laptop or
something and test it and see what FPS
you get and print the FPS to the screen
and stuff and you have to test it on
different computers because um you know
might be fine on like a gtx 260 or
something that like you know on a laptop
with a mobile graphics card you know you
might you might get like two frames per
second so testing is really important um
and one more thing let's test out the
horizontal movement as well add time to
here that's working okay awesome and
yeah of course i've noticed the fact
that this is going one way and this
going the other way and it's doing the
same thing here where this is going to
sort of going this is going the right
way we're going forward here but this is
sort of this is this is weird
don't worry about that that's easily
fixed I'm not worrying about that at the
moment I'll fix that in a minute and
diagonal yeah awesome okay
so every yep movements working fine
that's good I thought that might not be
smooth but it turned out to be fine okay
so how do we fix the the fact that
there's a sort of going different ways
pretty easily let me just okay all we
have to do here is say um all we have to
do here is say if if our arm if our
ceiling is less than zero then I'm
basically invert it so set it to equal
to minus ceiling and yeah that worked
simple fix honestly it's pretty easy you
guys probably would have figured it out
by yourself you thought about it yeah
and again we got horizontal movement and
that's all good and I hope diagonals
good I don't know whoa
- yeah awesome so that is that's really
good okay awesome weave weave yeah
fantastic okay yeah awesome
so we've made yeah we've made a lot of
progress actually today more than I
thought we would have time for what time
is that sixteen minutes that's fine if
you guys getting one episode per week
you might as well have a long one am i
right and I'll see you guys a few
episodes back if you would prefer long
episodes of short episodes you guys said
long episode so here you go yeah so
we've achieved quite a bit actually
let's actually no we don't want to if we
put this into this full loop I suspect
yes I'm doing gonna
okay plus time okay
so awesome we've up one thing I want to
actually do real quick let's see if this
what's going on oh wow that's not good
okay one thing I want to do real quick
is actually sort of clean up this code
times that yeah okay let me just some
pop this and 15 into here that's not
again I get rid of this basically back
out and work put some brackets
okay yes that that made it a bit better
um actually I don't
hmm I want to do one more thing and I'm
just going to name it X pixels and
that'll be the cost int of X X because I
really want to keep this as a double
actually now that I think about it so
let's get rid of this and this and this
and all of this yeah what is this
supposed to be sad plus time yeah okay
and set this to a double-double and
picks Y picks okay awesome that works um
yeah so I
okay here's another thing we can do okay
this is another question I'm asking you
guys it's all about what you want to do
okay there's two options for a foot for
our next episode okay we could either
one do the actual you know tacks
textures and getting actual textures
applied to these two days arm squares or
we could move on to some rotation so
we've we've done horizontal we've sort
of done horizontal line I guess depth
movement but would you guys like to do
some maybe you'd like you you guys would
like to do some rotation instead of
texturing okay so go ahead and click on
click on my maybe my username to go to
my channel page and they'll actually be
a section there with a question and just
you know just thumbs up what would like
which one you'd like to do okay
textures or um or rotation okay because
I'm because I really want to want to
sort of make what you guys want want me
to do okay so check it's a good go go go
go go to my um go to my channel page
I'm really tired actually kind of aspect
probably go go to my channel page
and there will be basically an area
there where you can vote for which for
which thing you would like me to do next
okay so yeah thanks for watching guys be
sure to thumbs up the video if you guys
enjoyed this we've achieved a lot today
and on Sunday so that's actually you're
sort of getting like a midweek episode
here the next episode will be in like
four days okay so be sure to go ahead
and and vote for what you want me to do
next okay I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you